welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Maryland Wilkes your host and our guest
is Marsha in horn the William que lambon
professor of anthropology and
international affairs a specialist on
Middle Eastern gender religion and
health professor in horn has conducted
research on the social impact of
infertility and assisted reproductive
technologies in Egypt Lebanon the United
Arab Emirates and Arab America over the
past 30 years she's the author of five
books on the subject as well as nine
edited volumes today we'll talk with
professor in horn about her new book
cosmopolitan conceptions IVF sojourn in
global Dubai welcome professor in horn
thank you for inviting me it's so nice
to have you back on the show again with
us it's a pleasure so let's begin with
an overview of your book tell tell us
about it and its premise yes so
infertility is a global reproductive
health problem that probably affects as
many as about fifteen percent of the
world's population a reproductive age
people who have trouble having a child
and for many of those cases of
infertility the only recourse in terms
of overcoming it in order to have a
child is to try in vitro fertilization
and assisted reproductive technology but
in many countries there is no in vitro
fertilization or it's very expensive or
it's legally restricted in some way or
it's simply just not available and
because of that there are thousands
perhaps even millions of infertile men
women and couples traveling the world
trying to access in vitro fertilization
which I'll just call IVF from this point
on trying to get it in places where they
can safely affordably access it okay and
how did you come to be interested in
this topic I've been a scholar of
infertility for really my entire life
I'm up my career I'm a medical
anthropologist and I have always been
interested in social suffering stigma
what makes people you know kind of
miserable and
the reproductive world if you want to
have children and you can't do it you
know your body doesn't cooperate it's a
really profound heartache you know for
people it's a source of real profound
suffering and so I started you know
looking at infertility in Egypt in in
the late 1980s and it was just at the
beginning of in vitro fertilization ivf
making a test tube baby had just become
possible in the UK and i really started
following the spread of ivf into the
muslim Middle East I'm a scholar of the
Middle East and so I've been really
studying the impact of IVF in places
like Egypt Lebanon and the United Arab
Emirates which is the topic of my most
recent book ok so I would imagine that
it is a painful topic for many people
I'm curious to know how you did the
research for the book yes so for this
particular book called cosmopolitan
conceptions IVF sojourn Xin global Dubai
I was interested in Dubai one of the
seven united arab emirates and it's a is
really a global city now with about two
million people in it and it's become a
kind of hub what i'm calling a repro hub
or a medical tourism hub for people
coming from really about a third of the
world's nations flying into dubai to try
to access medical care and in this case
IVF and so I ended up situating myself
in what I call a kind of cosmopolitan
clinic a clinic called conceived in the
emirate in Dubai actually on the border
of Dubai in the neighboring emirate of
sharjah and it was a clinic that had
really developed a kind of global
reputation as a safe affordable
effective place to go seek IVF and so I
literally in staying in this clinic for
about half a year I literally
interviewed about 220 people I call
repro travelers coming from 50 different
countries around the world i'm seeking
ivf okay and they had no problem
speaking with you know you know for the
most part because they had been through
a very sort of tortuous journeys to get
there they had you know often it was a
place of last resort they had spent a
lot of money they had struggled so much
to get to this point
usually they wanted to speak to me about
their sort of travails their journeys
their sojourn why they had come to this
particular clinic and so no I ended up
really you know talking to men women and
couples together from really all over
the world i would say every part of the
world was represented except for latin
america and the caribbean because that's
very far away from Dubai but there were
people coming from Europe from the UK
from the US Australia many people coming
from other Middle Eastern countries and
many people coming from parts of Asia
South Asia India Pakistan Sri Lanka
Malaysia Indonesia so it's really you
know it was a sight of global these kind
of Cosmopolitan conceptions as I came to
think of it I am wondering why dubai of
all places is it so much cheaper i mean
when you mentioned people from the
united states in the UK and europe going
that's surprising to me so why do you
think dubai is emerging as this medical
repro hub yeah part of it is statecraft
part of it is due by trying to become a
place of medical care a kind of global
medical tourism site I mean Dubai
specializes in international tourism
it's a global tourism and shopping hub
but they have actually developed
something called Dubai healthcare city
which we would call a med asst it II a
kind of small tax free zone where they
have you know hundreds of medical
professionals and clinics and people can
travel there the clinic I was working in
was not located in Dubai healthcare city
but the point is that Dubai is trying to
develop a sort of global medical tourism
reputation and because of that people
think of Dubai particularly in certain
parts of the world is the kind of go to
place to get a sort of higher quality of
medical care than they can access in
their home countries and so for example
there were many people coming from the
eastern coasts of Africa sub-saharan
Africa people coming from Somalia
Djibouti Tanzania where there are no IVF
clinics and so for them it's sort of
proximity and this kind of reputation of
being a place where you could safely
access health care for people coming
from the west and there were many people
in my study coming from the West it's
not that it was less expensive in fact
Dubai actually
offers rather expensive IVF it costs
about 5000 to 6000 US dollars to do a
cycle of IVF in the UAE but that is less
than half of the price of a cycle of IVF
in the United States the u.s. is the
most expensive place in the world to do
IVF the average hears about 12,000 US
dollars and most people don't have
health insurance to cover it IVF is not
considered to be something that it's
considered to be a kind of elective
procedure rather than a medical
necessity and so in the US that's not
covered and so people really have to
spend a lot of money to try to access it
in this country so yes some people from
the US will actually go travel to other
countries to try to access less costly
more affordable IVF care and you're in
the prologue of you of your book you
write about Rania why did you choose to
write about her and tell us a little bit
about her reproductive journey yes so I
decided to focus on the story a very
poignant story in a very kind of
capacious very fully detailed story of a
woman who I call Rania it's not a real
name she was an Ethiopian Eritrean
refugees to the UK she had left as a
teen to escape you know political
violence and was a refugee and now a
citizen of the United Kingdom and she
had met another refugee a Sudanese
refugee and they had married and they
had a very tumultuous path they had
trouble getting pregnant she had tried
eight IVF cycles in the UK I mean under
the National Health Service in the UK
actually will subsidise cycles for
people and so she had tried you know
subsidized IVF in the UK which hadn't
worked she'd gone to the private ivf
sector in the UK and through all of that
she had ended up with one daughter and
being an African woman you know in her
community in the UK she lived in a kind
of african community in the UK she was
stigmatized as being a woman really
without children she had one daughter
but you know in her society people had
four or five children and she
desperately wanted to have at least one
more child to be a sibling to her her
daughter sure and so through a variety
of circumstances she ended up coming to
this clinic called conceived in she came
to Dubai
hoping to try to get access to IVF that
she could afford and would be safe and
she had a very difficult time she
unbeknownst to her had a reproductive
tract infection that was sort of inside
her body and when she came to the UAE to
do another a 9th ivf cycle it sort of
released this hidden infection and she
became septic she had sort of a full
infection that was life-threatening they
were able to treat it you know cure it
and sent her back to the UK and said you
know you need to have parts of your
reproductive body actually removed
because they're infected and and they're
hurting you more than helping you and
still still wanting to have a child she
came back to Dubai she came back to the
UAE and she was successful she did two
more tries of IVF there and she ended up
having two more children a daughter and
a son the last part of her story which I
stood highlight in the end of the book
she tried one more time in the UAE when
she was about 43 years of age it was her
13th ivf cycle it didn't work and so she
didn't get you know another child but
she ended up having three IVF children
through incredible determination
thousands of you know dollars and to
sort of have a normative life as a
mother of children mm-hmm okay so let's
talk about the main reasons people
travel to places like Dubai for I via
yeah there's sort of four main reasons
why people to travel and I'll just sort
of go through them briefly one is what
we might call resource constraints and
that is that frankly in sub-saharan
Africa for example of the 55 countries
only 15 countries even have an IVF
clinic so there are many places of
absence where there is no IVF and people
literally have to leave the country in
order to access it and then they're
these cost considerations people wanting
to go for more affordable IVF care and i
would say cost is a huge issue driving
people looking for less expensive places
to go for IVF another huge area of
consideration is legal issues legal
constraints especially in Western Europe
Western European countries often provide
IVF on the state sort of subsidizes it
but they're often legal reasons why you
can't access it especially if you're
sick
engl if you're in a gay relationship or
if you're over 40 or for men who are
infertile there are particular reasons
why it's legally prohibited to certain
categories of male infertility and so
there are many people in Europe who are
traveling across borders trying to get
legal access to IVF and when they can't
we call them la evaders or i call them
reproductive outlaws they're literally
trying to evade laws by traveling to
other countries to access you know IVF
that's legal in other places let me ask
you this if they if they are successful
in getting pregnant through IVF and they
go back to where they have come from is
there any ramifications usually not
because you know they become pregnant
and nobody can ask how they did it they
just come back there's only one country
in the world that has tried to prevent
people from actually going out and
coming back and that's Turkey which is
an interesting case in and of itself but
yes oh no you know they evade the law by
leaving the country trying to get
pregnant and they come back and then
there are sort of what we might call
quality issue quality and safety issues
people not trusting their home country
health care for example that you need
hormones in order to stimulate a woman's
reproductive cycle to get the IVF going
and in some countries there are fake
medicines you know people in Nigeria for
example are very concerned that it's not
really you know going to be efficacious
if they do it in their home country and
they're concerned about safety not just
in Nigeria but in many parts of the
world where they feel that the quality
of medical care is simply not good in
their home home country it's a safety
and efficacy and sort of quality and
doing it in a place where you feel
comfortable that is safe and you know
effective is very important and then
there are a whole host of one what we
might call sort of socio-cultural issues
people concerned about medical privacy
people actually concerned if they do IVF
in their home country that people are
going to talk about them that it won't
be confidential they don't want to be
seen by people that they might run into
an IVF clinic and so they will move and
sometimes people move just to have sort
of linguistic and cultural connection
with providers and so there are sort of
cultural subtle nuances of you know
cultural considerations and so these are
sort of four categories
why people are are traveling and
together it's a lot of reasons actually
why people would seek IVF outside of
their home country right so it seems
like it will just keep growing and
growing for Dubai yeah and around the
world they're showing that people are
traveling to parts of Latin America
people are really traveling traveling
there are now really thousands perhaps
millions of repro travelers there really
isn't a good study but the few studies
that have been done have shown that
thousands of people are traveling trying
to access IVF in other parts of the
world Wow very interesting thank you for
being here with us today for speaking
with me about my book okay and good luck
with it thank you so much Carolyn for
more information about professor in horn
and her research please visit our
website at macmillan report yale edu be
sure to join us again for another
episode of the macmillan report made
possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Center for
International and area studies at Yale